hi ben
uh thanks for doing the tomahawk chop
very epic thank you you bet you know
when people say that that's like a
racist thing i have to say if people
just went to a stadium and started
cheering for the jews you know how happy
i would be
um so my question is very quick um what
is your favorite argument for god's
existence and why
okay so my favorite argument for god's
existence is that i believe in free will
okay the reason that i think this is an
argument for god's existence is because
if you believe that human beings are
essentially just balls of meat wandering
around aimlessly in the universe the
kind of spinoza's stone that thinks that
it was
moving of its own accord but actually
was thrown if you believe that and you
don't believe in free will then there's
an internal coherence and logic to it if
you believe that you have the ability to
make independent choices that you can
actually supersede your own biologic
your own biological drives and the
environment around you to any extent
even to the smallest extent this means
that you believe in something that can't
actually be proved by science but that
you are living every single day and the
notion that you have that will and not
only that you have that will but that
that will is capable of comprehending
the universe around you that your will
is sort of your ideas your ability to
comprehend the universe is a reflection
of a reality of an objective truth that
is out there that says to me that there
is a god that there's a common source
that stands behind that objective truth
and stands behind the mind that can
comprehend that truth or sort of
conscient argument for the existence of
god
[Applause]
why do you believe you're right about
trans people given the american
psychological association american
medical association american
psychoanalytic association i can go on
for about five more associations
um that are very prominent and govern
the um the existing like health uh
health government or
health industries within
like the major western countries
and all of these associations have
multiple thousands of doctors
sociologists psychologists and with phds
in their respective fields backing the
idea that sex and gender are different
effectively gaining the medical
consensus for sex and gender being two
different concepts yet you have a
different opinion okay so sex and gender
are two different concepts but gender is
tied to biology so one of the big
problems that you see in sort of the the
argument in favor of trans rights is
this notion that gender and sex are
completely separable they're not
completely separable if they are
completely separable then this means
that identifying people by their
subjective gender really has no
relevance as to whether they are a male
or female male and female are biological
terms so using terminology like male and
female to describe a self-described
perception of of maleness or femaleness
is sort of a bizarre way of arguing
whether a thing is a man or a woman so
here is my question it's an argument
that my friend matt walsh likes to make
what is a woman define what a woman is
without reference to the word woman
please
um so this is actually a logical fallacy
called a red herring you're asking me a
question in
or um in order to actually challenge my
question without actually no it isn't
i'm saying that it really is not i'm
saying that biology i'm agreeing with
you that the notion of gender which is
effeminateness or masculinity can be
different from biology in the sense that
biology is just pure male or pure female
but to suggest that there is such a
thing as an effeminate male is not to
suggest that an effeminate male is now a
woman
transgenderism makes the argument that
if you believe that you are a woman you
are there for a woman or if you believe
that you are a man you are there for a
man i disagree with this there are
objective measures as to whether you're
a man or a woman they're objective
measures as to whether you're male or
female you're there there's certainly a
spectrum when with regards to
effeminateness versus masculinity that's
certainly true but that does not change
the underlying sexual dichotomy that is
the basis for all human reproduction
yeah you can
answer um right so this dichotomy is a
false dichotomy that isn't supported by
any of the medical associations that i
just named then let me explain medical
associations that i just named off would
actually support the uh idea that um
gender is biological this is something
that's completely untrue within every
single like medical consensus well then
i will just say that anyone who suggests
that gender has no reference whatsoever
to biology it's not connected in any way
to biology it's just full of
because if they see and the reason i
and
and the re and the reason that i say
then you then you class it then you
actually just disagree with medical
consensus yes
yes i disagree with the false medical
consensus driven by politically driven
quote unquote doctors if any doctor
denies to me that there is a dichotomy
between male and female a sexual
dichotomy between male and female they
are ignorant and they're letting their
politics get in the way of their science
anybody who suggests to you that there
is such a thing for example as a
pregnant male is not a doctor they are
an activist
[Applause]
i'm very glad that none of these
opinions are actually accepted in
academia and haven't been for over 70
years synth is here on the wall okay so
the notion that they haven't been
accepted for over 70 years is a bizarre
one considering they were accepted until
about five minutes ago and the basic
idea that male and female do not exist
runs counter to all mammalian biology
all of it not just human are we to
suggest that gender and and sex are
different in walruses how does this work
exactly like
are they different in bears any time you
have a any time you have all mammalian
reproduction is rooted in the idea that
there's a sexual dichotomy between male
and female to obscure that with all
sorts of semantic word games about how
you feel subjectively has no bearing on
whether male and female are categories
that exist and if you're trying to
define male and female with reference to
any subjective category that cannot be
identified by any metric whatsoever
other than how you feel today i
challenge whether that is scientific or
whether that is merely a self-perception
that is being guided by a political
agenda i'm sorry i spent more time on
this but we have to get to the next
question i appreciate it
[Applause]
hey benjamibo good to see you
hey everybody here good to see you guys
too i'm glad to be here i got in on the
stand in line so i'm really happy to be
here um do you know about the bill that
republicans are trying to pass to stop
critical race theory being taught in
college um i'm aware that there isabelle
i haven't read the text of it but go
ahead
okay so in florida i think it's going to
go
oh i look sick um
so it's going to be
decided i guess we're going to talk
about it in like december um yeah in the
new legislative session correct yes go
ahead so as a republican being pro free
speech
do you have anything to say against this
like we're really
simply just outlawing certain words to
be used
in public spheres such as education
um i feel like more republicans should
kind of seem see this as concerning you
know you guys always quote uh 18 1984 or
whatever
um you know this is like an orwellian
move isn't it so so it depends on what
level of education we're talking about
if we're talking about the idea that
critical race theory can be taught as
one of many theories on college campuses
i have no problem with it marxism is
taught as one of many theories on
college campuses if the idea is that
we're going to be teaching critical race
theory which is not
taught as one of many theories it's
taught as a framework for understanding
the world and it is a lens through which
we are to view history this is something
that the founders of critical race
theory openly acknowledge they suggest
the critical race theory has a praxis
component meaning it's a practice
component that is designed in order to
indoctrinate kids in a particular type
of thinking about how america's
institutions work do i think that the
taxpayers of the state of florida have
an obligation to subsidize the
indoctrination of their children in that
no and i think that public education as
an institution is dedicated not merely
to the idea that you send your kids to
school then the teachers dump whatever
they want on your kids i think the idea
is that these the parents delegate their
power to educate their children to the
state
via the public schools and then they
have the authority and should have the
authority to determine what framework is
being taught and the anti-american
framework of critical race theory which
is unrooted in actual history ought not
be taught in america's public schools
um
like critical race theory is literally a
footnote in my sociology class and it's
a framework if you want to take it in as
a framework listen i learned critical
race there when i was at harvard law
school too right i mean i i
facts whenever you talk about critical
race theory you say the right things you
know what you're talking about but
because you're republican it's the
talking point to go against no they are
i'm a pro free speech american so this
deeply concerns me when are
words exact words that are being
restricted
in the public sphere well that's why i
just ended up by saying marketplace of
ideas so i'm a big marketer right so i i
again i would distinguish between
marketplace of ideas in the college
realm and mark when presumably people
are old enough to actually understand
what they're talking about have open and
interesting debates about these topics
and when you're talking about 11 year
olds or 10 year olds or when you're
talking about reading ibramax candy
which is a really dumbed down version of
critical race theory for five-year-olds
for colleges not for eleven-year-olds
well then i'll have colleges i'd be
happy to look at the text of the bill
and determine what i think about the
bill i do think that public schools i'm
not sure that public schools have an
obligation to teach as practical
critical race theory again i think there
are different ways that it's taught so
if we're talking about just in your
sociology class it's one of many
theories about american history and now
we're going to talk about how it applies
i don't really have a problem with that
being taught if we're talking about
critical race theory being taught as a
framework to view america's institutions
to the exclusion of other frameworks i
do have a problem with that
thank you
hello um so earlier on in your lecture
you were saying that
due process past the 14th amendment has
been equally distributed to all groups
across america no
i said i said i i didn't say that in
practice it has i said the concept of
due process is dedicated to the
proposition that people should be
treated as individuals obviously
segregation and and racism and criminal
justice up until the civil rights act
would suggest that on a practical level
it was not equally distributed obviously
okay so an idea but in practice it was
you agree that it was um
not equally distributed to all groups
across america sure okay so then
wouldn't that how is that in opposition
to
um critical race theory that teaches
that these institutions have been used
to um prosecute certain groups
differently than others have been
prosecuted because that's not what
critical race theory teaches what
critical race theory teaches is that
supposedly colorblind institutions like
due process of law or cover for racism
as a as an institution due process of
law is a problem because it is not
because it is a good concept badly
applied or
improperly applied it's because it is in
and of itself a discriminatory concept
right this is what they said by
capitalism also right free market
economies are inherently discriminatory
they are covers for institutions of
power that's the critique the critique
is that due process of law in and of
itself the idea of treating people
individually ignores key components
about human beings namely how they are
seen racially by other human beings and
thus due process of law is not enough to
guarantee that people are treated
equally or can be treated equally i
disagree i think due process of law is
an excellent guarantee and straying away
from that guarantee has been the problem
with regard to process of law not the
actual guarantee itself
okay
sorry my voice is a bit gone um
so then would you agree not banning
critical race theory in public inst um
like in theory that in the theory that
they are covers what would you be a
proponent of having the education that
these institutions have been used to
attack other minority groups across
america and that it has had historic um
scars that are still um rep that um we
still see today so i wouldn't say that
the institutions have been used to abuse
dupri i wouldn't say due process of law
has been used to abuse minorities i
would say that people have refused to
implement due process of law because
they wanted to abuse minorities of
course and of course you'd have to teach
about that i mean that's the entire
history of segregation and the
subjugation of black americans up to the
civil rights act for sure of course and
this is why it's such a lie when people
say that if you don't want to teach
critical race theory you don't want to
teach history i'm fine with teaching
every ugly part of american history what
i'm not fine with is the idea that the
foundational ideas of the united states
of america the notion that we are
created equal before god with certain
inalienable rights and the government
was instituted in order to protect these
rights i disagree with the fundamental
idea that these were a cover for power
designed in order to subjugate black
americans i think that's a lie and i
think it's deleterious to teach that to
kids
[Applause]
right here
okay so um i don't want to misinterpret
your position but it's your belief tell
me if i'm right or wrong about this okay
um it's your belief that america is
fundamentally a skillsocracy as you call
it as as opposed to a meritocracy
correct
yes
okay
then how because i don't connect moral
merit with with intellect people are
born yeah yeah okay
nice um that's good uh the um my
question is how do you explain the fact
that the vast majority of american
inequality is caused by the people who
you know the neighborhoods you grew up
in the amount of wealth your parents
have and thousands and thousands and
thousands of other whether you believe
that race is involved or not but
thousands of other non-skill based
factors
um that are integral to moving head in
the american system so i don't think
that that's true primarily what i think
is that all of those things have an
impact on the skills that manifest in
the marketplace
no question but what the market measures
is is at the point of the skills it's
not measure if there's a skilled person
who's coming from an impoverished
background where there's a lot of single
motherhood and crime for example and
that person has high skills that person
is going to do fine
okay but the problem is that all of
those things can contribute to a lack of
skills
right this is part of my argument and
the only way to to actually alleviate
that problem is to change the cultural
milieu that makes it very difficult for
people to achieve a certain level of
skills in particular communities
single motherhood makes it very
difficult for example for kids to grow
up in an environment where they have a
solid family home where they're studying
a lot at home where education is is of
primary value as opposed to just getting
through the day crime free for example
and without being victimized by
neighbors high crime areas right all of
these things are things that we can
alleviate and i think that we should
alleviate them these are real problems
to people fully developing their skills
the point that i'm making is that the
system of economics is not punishing
people for their upbringing it's
punishing them for lack of skills which
may in fact be an effect of their
upbringing
right but but that does not mean that
primarily the skills occurrency is
punishing people for their for for their
environment or for their race it is
punishing them for the fact that when it
comes time for them to go to the job
market they don't have the same skills
as the person next to them so the
question becomes not how do we get rid
of the skillsocracy the question becomes
how do we get rid of the obstacles to
people who could be more skilled
becoming more skilled
and that means creating cultural
institutions that matter it means
creating communities it means trying to
ensure that people have a father and a
mother in the home trying to make sure
that people can live in safe
neighborhoods where there are thriving
communities where there are jobs
available
right that would that would effectuate a
better opportunity set to enter the
skillsocracy but what i see is people
attacking the distribution of reward at
the skills level as opposed to attacking
the underlying problem which creates a
lot of the inequalities you're talking
about
[Applause]
yeah so i was wondering you so you
believe that um things like single
motherhood things like growing up in
high crime areas are inherently cultural
rather than to do with any institutions
or any inequalities uh that are part of
american society institutionally no i
think that history has a long tail but i
think that the only way that you fix
that is by changing the incentive
structure for individuals right now
so i think that you can blame the the
the amount of crime in a particular
community on a long history of
disinvestments in that community 50 60
years ago i don't think it's going to
change a damn thing and i don't think
pouring money into the community is
necessarily the solution i think if
you're looking at high crime levels i
think the best solution is you need more
cops on the ground to stop the crime
this is what's going to allow people to
invest in the area and provide more jobs
and i think that trying to spend all of
your time the question is are we trying
to
are we trying to diagnose a problem that
is solvable or are we trying to just
describe the history of the problem if
we want to describe the history of the
problem that's fine but using that as a
substitute for a practical solutions
based approach to problems is a
political mistake one is the study of
historians the other is the study of
politicians and political actors that
ought to actually be applied in real
life
so when you have a solution like
affirmative action or you have a
solution like
benefiting people from lower income
communities and i know obviously there's
a difference between affirmative action
on the racial level and affirmative
reaction on the economic level you think
that
government policy should have no role in
uh in alleviating those inequalities
even though government policy
purportedly in the past even though i
would argue currently created those
inequalities in the first place i think
that any time the government attempts to
remedy past discrimination by the use of
current discrimination all they are
doing is effectuating discrimination and
undermining the skillsocracy that allows
for positive externalities yes
[Applause]
hi ben how are you
doing okay how are you great
um how come you claim to be five nine
even though you're like five five
i don't know how tall are
you you're five nine i'm actually fine
okay come over here let's see
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
i'll be honest i planned it i'm waiting
years to do that
hi how are you um my question is
regarding two very high profile court
cases going on right now the uh ahmed
arbory trials and the kyle ridden house
trials and my question is
what do you believe would be the outcome
of these trials and why okay so i think
that there's what will happen what
should happen i'm not going to try and
predict what will happen because he
cannot predict what juries are going to
do what should happen right now should
be acquitted
he clearly acted in self-defense
that doesn't mean that i would send my
17 year old over to kenosha wisconsin in
order to protect property and provide
medical aid to people but it does mean
that the shootings that he committed
were in self-defense the evidence is
pretty much as clear as day on that one
uh and uh the prosecutor has no case and
frankly he's making a fool of himself he
looks like at his law degree for turning
in the tops of cracker jack boxes um
in the arbory case the the main question
in the arbory case is going to come down
to legally speaking whether the whether
the mcdaniels who are the the defendants
in this particular case whether they had
the capacity under the citizens arrest
law of georgia to arrest our birds there
was some testimony last week that a
couple of weeks before they went after
arbory
and they were they went to this house
that arbory had been allegedly inside of
this this construction site and tools
had been stolen from there and all this
they went there with a local cop
apparently and the local cop was
speaking to them about how there was
somebody who looked exactly like arbor
who'd been inside stealing things right
and so what this does it provides the
predicate for the notion they have to
that if they get a call that somebody is
stealing things and that person matches
arbori's description
and and the cop in the tape says it's
possible he's stealing things it could
be a misdemeanor it could be a felony
once it's a felony you can effectuate a
citizen's arrest so the question is
going to be whether that citizen's
arrest was lawful or not the attempted
citizens arrest because once you get
down to the the end of it right the end
of it where they they're road blocking
him and they're trying to keep him from
running away and arbury runs between the
cars now you essentially have a case of
almost mutual self-defense right it's
actually really a terrible case in which
arberry sees these guys chasing him in
trucks
why is he going to pull over right and
so he tries to run he goes for the gun
they shoot him so from their perspective
they're trying to give the citizens
citizen's arrest they have to shoot him
in self-defense from his perspective
he's trying to run away and they're
blocking him and trying to falsely
imprison him and so he's acting in
self-defense so the only way to solve
that legal conundrum is whether they
were in fact
under the belief that they were
attempting to arrest him a citizen's
arrest and they had good cause like uh
it has to be by the preponderance of the
evidence like 51 49 standard if they had
probably if they had um a 51 to 49
probability of the evidence that he was
committing a felony and that they could
arrest him then they could be acquitted
so that's the legal issue that's what
it's going to come down to
considering that citizen's arrest is a
widely outdated law do you consider that
it should be reformed
um you know it's it's difficult to
reform citizens arrest because again
they're they're just so many areas where
the cops are not available i mean what i
would like is to make it so that
citizen's arrest is not something that
anybody really wants to do because the
cops are so available that you just call
them
right and by the way this is what
happens in
in in low crime
high income areas frankly there are a
lot of cops available there's a lot of
security you don't see a lot of people
running around trying to effectuate
citizens arrests in those areas you
typically have somebody calling a police
officer
and uh sorry one last question is do you
believe that rittenhouse traveled to
kenosha with the intent of stirring
trouble or not
um i think that by the available
evidence he went there with the intents
of providing medical aid and brought the
gun because he thought the trouble was
might break out or could break out i
don't think that he went there to shoot
anybody if that's the question and i
think the prosecution's case that he
went there to shoot somebody is
undermined by pretty much every single
fact on the ground including his own
behavior that night
[Applause]
hi ben how you doing okay how are you
i'm good um so in our country we have a
lot of billionaires we have a lot of
companies that are worth billions of
dollars it's a great country sure
so so tesla uses lithium mines in africa
where children are employed they're paid
very little amounts of money they're
starving
nike uses children in asia where they're
working with textiles and they are
injured frequently these are all
dangerous conditions uh all these
companies all these billionaire
billionaire companies
have these similar like problems at the
bottom ring
do you think that
that do you think that that's
exploitation do you think that
exploitation is a problem and do you
think that your idea of free market
capitalism has an answer for
exploitation
so
so i think that every economic system
has a problem of exploitation if it's
not bound by certain levels of morality
right socialism has a level of
exploitation too which you see in the
soviet union for example you can treat
workers as chattel and you can treat
them as trash and you can force them
into doing jobs they don't want to go
log them so any system of economics that
relies on on force is a form of
exploitation i would say that the
problem that you see with regard to
china is not per se free markets it's
the fact that the chinese government is
willing to allow its own citizens to be
used as child labor and the fact that
there is no governance structure in
africa at all to protect children if
what you're saying about tesla is true
i'm going to assume that it is i don't
know enough about the issue
so assuming that that is the case
there's nothing in free market
capitalism that
prohibits people who are incapable of
making decisions for themselves
from being exploited that's true right i
mean if you can find somebody who's this
particularly true child labor children
are not capable of consent if children
are incapable of consent then free
market conditions should not prevail and
there should be laws on the books that
prevent companies from actually using
that sorts of labor we've had child
labor laws in the united states for
quite a while and i agree with those
so but that's not to suggest that any
other economic system wouldn't be
similarly prone to exactly the same
kinds of problem as long as you are
saying that that exploitation is simply
a function of economic growth
or even economic distribution right
they're almost two separate issues so
one is an issue of morality immoral
people can use any system in order to
harm other people and particularly
children and people who can't protect
themselves
the case that socialism makes is that
people who are fully capable of consent
are also exploited and that i think is a
lie
well do you do you think that
um
i apologize oh no worries i just tripped
up but
um
yeah i'm sorry that's okay i mean i
think the the broader point that i'm
making is that when it comes to sorry
did you remember so yeah so would you be
in favor of legislation here in the
united states that prevents billionaire
companies and multi-billion dollar
companies from using exploitation around
the world
uh depending on what we are defining as
exploitation sure i mean if we're
talking about like forcing small
children to make nike shoes absolutely
yes
child labor yes okay
yes okay well and by the way we're in
agreement and by the way we're in
agreement yeah and and by the way i
would agree with with a united states
policy of tariffing any company abroad
that also uses similar levels of labor
because the big problem is that the
reason companies in the united states
presumably do that sort of stuff is in
order to compete with companies abroad
that are using exactly that sort of
labor so punishing those companies
abroad from doing that would also be a
way of preventing them from entering
american markets and undercutting
companies that are now undergoing the
higher labor cost of having to not use
small children to make shoes
[Applause]
all right uh hello i just wanted to ask
so i want to bring up the fact that you
talked about individuals and everything
and
i wanted to bring up a few examples like
for example like covet and like say like
the 2008 financial collapse and even
like the 1994 crime bill and things like
that those have definitely effects on
big groups and especially like the black
community and everything like after the
2008 financial collapse
not many people got you know
like i wouldn't say cues but convicted
for example not many people on wall
street the individuals who did profit a
lot from those things
but millions of people were kicked out
of their homes and everything and you
talk about like
us things like these being or america
being you know based on individuals and
individuals wanting to achieve different
things but in reality
a lot of like people are affected by
their societal factors you know their
environment and everything so i want to
get your answer on that and like how
these negative effects
you know
affect the majority of people but a
positive positives the money gains you
know the wall street things
not many of the working-class people in
tallahassee for example feel that you
know not many people in tallahassee felt
the uh after covid or during covid you
know the stock market jumps the average
employer just saw a bunch of just empty
you know
employment you know options and low
wages and everything still and the same
old same also well i mean okay so i
think that the fundamental idea with
regard to it's almost two separate
questions and so i'm going to take them
one at a time the reason i'm separating
the questions is because when it comes
to corporate bailouts for example i'm
sure you and i agree i don't think that
any of those corporations should have
been bailed out i think that if you
engage in the moral hazard of wrecking
your own company i don't see why i'm
supposed to pay for that or you're
supposed to pay for that
in a free market system you're supposed
to bear the consequences of the risks
that you take i think that's true across
the board and i think that whether
you're a big rich guy on wall street and
you lose your entire company or whether
you're a guy who took out a loan that
you couldn't afford on your house if you
take out too much
that is as i
am constantly representing a you problem
if you take a risk and then you bear the
consequence of that risk that's no one's
fault but your own and anybody who comes
in to bail you out from that
particularly if you're talking about
like billions of dollars in order to
prop up a particular lifestyle that's a
huge mistake and it's a huge problem and
i totally agree
with that
and um for example with that like
you know we in america we do bail these
people out you know our capitalist
system does not it's not capitalism
that's cronyism definitely yeah people
say that but no but it's true it's it's
nobody we do bail these people out right
i'm just saying that that's not
capitalism that's actually closer to
corporatism which is the government
being in control of the economy
essentially i mean
where is who's bailing them out i mean
are they bailing them out the government
is bailing definitely the government and
for example we don't get these similar
bailouts for regular people like for
example joe biden was you know promoting
just two thousand dollars you know we're
fighting for scraps i want to understand
like where does that come from like why
are we so you know willing to get i mean
the united states does spend
literally trillions of dollars on social
welfare programs the notion the united
states has no social safety net at all
is not true the united states spends
per citizen
tens of thousands of dollars on on
social welfare benefits ranging from
medicaid to food stamps to
unemployment insurance to a wide variety
of programs the notion that we're wildly
out of line with europe is just not
borne out by the statistical facts
actually it's kind of an american myth
that we tell ourselves that we don't
spend any money on this sort of stuff
it's not true since the beginning of the
war on poverty we spent something like
22 trillion dollars on various social
programs and essentially the same number
of people live underneath the poverty
line okay and then last question so we
have this uh infrastructure bill going
through and you see people like joe
manchin you know arguing over
you know what is it five billion dollars
in regards to it or just you know just a
little price difference for example
over the past 20 years we've been
fighting wars in afghanistan and we
spent trillions and billions of dollars
and you have these politicians saying
that these infrastructure bills that
will help us
on our domestic front
these small price changes are going to
have dramatic effects on you know our
future and our children and that's why
they you know the republican party they
definitely you know go for austerity and
those you know factors so the wars to
take an example the wars in iraq and
afghanistan were expensive they cost
grand total somewhere between three and
four trillion dollars last i checked the
united states spends about four million
dollars in budget every single year we
spend about seven trillion dollars last
year that's every year right yeah i just
want to know what that what that means
for the future of our children if we're
willing to spend that much on war
like what does that mean in regards to
you know these infrastructure bills us
fighting over these small amounts
we're not really fighting over small
amounts these are very large amounts of
money the entire american budget 40
years ago was not nearly as much as one
of these infrastructure bills i mean 20
years ago it wasn't and just go back and
look at the budgeting so we're spending
unsustainable amounts of money on nearly
everything in american life to point out
defense spending as opposed to what
really constitutes the vast bulk of our
budget which is everything else defense
spending is a percentage of the american
budget is something like 20 25 of the
american budget i think it's even that
high
that that is not the chief driver of
systemic spending problems in the united
states it's these it's massive mandatory
spending programs i have to ask you a
question were you the guy before who i
saw a picture of holding uh the very
creative flag
of us yes it was yeah dude i just i got
to ask you like
lennon and stalin really yeah definitely
lennon and stalin it's just
stalin stalin definitely due to world
war ii you know i mean there's no
exploitation of people i mean stalin i
mean we do a lot of that in america too
i live in tallahassee there's a lot of
exploitation i used to work at a lot of
places and there's a lot of poor people
who logs though
we have prisons in america too
we have where you want to go like three
particularly people murdered by style
and like really really if you're gonna
if you're gonna go marxist then please
find a better marxist to emulate than
than lenin or stalin mass murderers
soviet union the soviet union during
world war ii
saved the world i would say that it had
not been for stalin world war i never
would have started because it was the
molotov ribbon trop pack that allowed
the nazi germans to believe that they
could invade eastern europe
this will be the last question that mr
shapiro takes for the evening
that's a lot of pressure um
my name is andrew
um and uh i used to i was introduced to
you by the michael knowles book reasons
to vote for democrats
your quote that said thorough at the top
and it was a blank book um and if anyone
was
familiar with that book um
but um
i uh
my question is um about uh
it's like
in the in the way that like the
the things that you're saying about
um
certain you know things being done with
hard work seeing things being done with
intellect um as kind of like a
you know a slippery slope to two more
right like you know
racist things or like white supremacist
things
um the question is like a fsu specific
question about
um
what your thoughts are about the
difference between
canceling someone for what they believe
and accountability
in a position where they should have
accountability um specifically jack
denton
who is a was an fsu i believe senate
person but he was basically he had um
sorry
i should be more knowledgeable about
this but um
and i really don't want to be the the
college student destroyed by ben shapiro
but um
but the question is basically he was a
he was an fsu student that um had
anti-blm anti uh transgender uh comments
in um
uh catholic group that he had the
facebook group or something if someone
wants to correct me on that they can but
a group me gotcha different application
okay um but the question is basically uh
what are your thoughts on that
you know
i mean so so my my basic view of council
culture i won't comment on a specific
case because i really don't know the
facts of the case but my general
thoughts on on cancel culture versus
what they call accountability culture is
you get to hold somebody accountable for
a thing that they do in the space where
they do it what i mean by that is i
speak on politics if i say something bad
about politics you cannot listen to my
show you can say that that i'm a bad man
and you should and you can come after me
and you can tell people not to listen to
me and all of that if you go after my
advertisers who are advertising on a
wide variety of programs then that is an
attempt to cancel as opposed to an
attempt to to hold accountable because
the person that you're actually
attempting to hold accountable is not me
you're attempting to go after
advertisers who have had nothing to say
about any of that my advertisers i
assume disagree with a lot of what i say
just because they advertise on the
program does not mean that they approve
of everything i say any more than they
agree with everything on msnbc if they
advertise on both of us um this this
holds true across
i would say industries so you see you'll
see a plumber and a plumber has some
sort of bad thing on a facebook page and
the idea is that you can no longer use
this plumber because what was on their
facebook page that they were talking
about politics that seems very silly to
me if you can unclog my toilet i'll use
you as the plumber these two things have
nothing whatsoever to do with each other
if it impacts your job performance
that's accountability culture if it
impacts not your job performance you
just impact sort of your public
perception that seems a lot more like
cancel culture to me
as a member of student government do you
think that he should be held accountable
to those beliefs i mean it depends who's
holding him accountable in other words
was he you'll have to tell me the story
did was he dumped by the school from his
position in the student senate or did
people just not elect him in the future
it was a vote of no confidence from the
um student government i mean i i can say
whether i disagree or agree with that
but i can also say that if a student
government votes that they don't want
somebody else in student government
because of something that they've said
politically then
i i can think that they are are being
censorious i'm not sure that that counts
as formal cancer culture in the sense
that they're being cancelled for
something that that is outside the
purview of which they're they're
normally speaking uh but i can still
think that the people are doing their
jackasses i don't know what he said
so both of those things can be true one
sometimes accountability culture as it's
called can also be misused it's not like
a hard divide between accountability
culture is good and canceled culture is
universally bad right i could probably
think of hypothetical scenarios where
that's not true